have reached the conclusion that this is
not a perfect bill well they're right
when while my problems with this bill
are very different than theirs I do hope
that in the weeks and months to come
after we pass this reconciliation
package that we will improve it but I
would ask my Republican colleagues to
tell me something when they controlled
the White House and they controlled the
Senate and they controlled the house
when President Bush was our president
during that period seven million more
Americans lost their health insurance
and health care costs soared where were
they then in talking about health care
did they have one substantive idea
during that period about how we were
going to lower the cost of health care
for Americans and provide health
insurance for all of our people mr.
president I do hope that after we pass
reconciliation we are going to improve
this bill and in that regard I want to
thank Senator Reid Majority Leader Reid
who has promised us and Anna Merkley
myself and others that we will have the
chance to vote on a public option
provision I think millions of Americans
understand that public option is a
choice that people should have the right
to go outside of the private insurance
companies for their health insurance and
that public option will provide
competitive pressure on the insurance
industry to control soaring health care
costs so I very much appreciate senator
Reed telling us that we are going to
have a vote on that issue within a
couple of months mr. president this bill
is a strong step forward it is no small
thing that we are providing health
insurance to 32 million more Americans
it's no small thing that we are moving
to eliminate pre-existing can
editions as a grounds for rejecting
someone for health care it is no small
thing that we're going to begin to fill
that doughnut hole so that seniors will
be able to get the prescription drugs
they need in an affordable way those are
among other achievements quite
significant but having said that after
the passage of this legislation we still
still have got to deal with the reality
that we will continue to spend far more
per capita on health care than any other
major country just a few days ago we had
an ambassador ambassador from Denmark
visiting vermont in that country they
provide quality care or all of their
people and they do it spending about
fifty percent of what they we do because
they have eliminated private insurance
companies and all of the administrative
and profiteering costs associated with
private insurance companies and I hope
that we will one day allow at least
States the option to move forward with a
single-payer medicare-for-all program
which I think ultimately is the way
we're going to go as a nation if we're
going to solve the need for
comprehensive universal and cost
effective healthcare for all of our
people but mr. president I do want to
say a word on one aspect one provision
of this bill which i think is enormously
important and I'm very very excited that
it is included in this bill and again I
want to thank Senator Reid for his help
in making sure that it remained in and
is amply fund and and that is that in
this legislation we are going to take a
giant step vote in providing primary
health care to the people of this
country through a major expansion of
community health centers and the
National Health Service Corps this
legislation provides enough funding so
that we are going to create over the
next five years eight thousand new
health center sites more than doubling
the number that now exists
we are going to increase access for
primary healthcare dental care mental
health counseling and low-cost
prescription drugs to an additional 20
million Americans in every state in
every region of this country that is a
huge step forward in providing basic
health care to millions of Americans who
today cannot access that care and while
we do that we are also going to
significantly expand the number of
doctors the number of nurse
practitioners and dentists that we
desperately need in order to provide
primary health care to our people this
legislation triples over a five-year
period triples the amount of money going
into the National Health Service Corps a
program which provides debt forgiveness
and scholarships for those doctors and
dentists who will be serving in
underserved areas throughout this
country we are going to provide an
additional 17,000 new primary health
care doctors dentists nurse
practitioners and mental health
professionals through this program and
what this means mr. president is that if
somebody has no health insurance if
somebody has medicaid if somebody has
Medicare if somebody has private health
insurance that individual is going to be
able to walk into a community health
center and get the high quality care
they need and the incredible thing mr.
president and this is really quite
remarkable is the by doing this we're
going to actually save taxpayers money
because we're going to keep people out
of the emergency room which is the most
expensive form of primary health care
we're going to prevent people from
becoming sicker than they should and
ending up in the hospital a great
expense mr. president this are this
legislation
all is going to be very significant in
providing the primary health care that
we need as a nation and I very
appreciative that senators time is
expired thank you very much Thunder from
Montana's wreckage time remains on to
our half hour two minutes and 40 seconds
raz ideal to mr. prysock is the center
of Missouri senator from Missouri is
recognized mr. president we have had a
lot of that childhood story that we all
learned of chicken little we've had a
lot of chicken little around this
building over the last few months the
sky is falling the sky is falling and
you know I woke up this morning I looked
up and the sky was not falling and every
day that goes by in America people are
going to realize the sky is not falling
in fact as time goes on that sky is
going to get bluer and brighter because
people in America are going to realize
that this bill is not full of booby
traps it's full of good things that were
reform health care but I rise this
afternoon just to take a couple of
minutes to talk about a new low of
obstructionism taking game playing to a
whole new level and that's I was
supposed to convene a hearing on the
contracts for police training in
Afghanistan now this is a very important
part of our mission in Afghanistan is
the training of local police departments
there was a witness as we're going to be
there from the State Department a
witness there from the Defense
Department the inspector general's were
going to be there and just last week Gao
wiped out a contract that had been let
on police training because the problems
in the way the contract was competed so
this hearing was timely and it's
important we cannot succeed in
Afghanistan if we do not have effective
police training and these contracts are
problematic the State Department is
supposed to be overseeing it we have
hundreds of millions of dollars it's not
a
down four so what do I find out this
morning the Republican Party is not
going to let us have the hearing what in
the world why in the world are we not
being allowed to work this afternoon why
in the world that I am are we not able
to ask questions at a hearing in a few
minutes as to why the police training is
not going well in Afghanistan and how we
can do better our men and women are over
there and they were at risk if we don't
get this right I don't get it I don't
get what the purpose of saying no is I
don't get what we accomplished we're
sitting here to work we're paid by the
people of this country to work and the
idea that I had to call these witnesses
and say go home because the Republicans
won't let us have a hearing somebody's
got to explain this to me disagree with
us the majority's 30 minutes has expired
vote no but let us work I implore you
let us work Thank You mr.